[Music]
you talking to me
you talking to me
[Music]
talking to me
[Music]
but who the hell else are you talking
talking to me
well i'm the only one here
[Music]
who the [ __ ] do you think you're talking
to
oh yeah huh
the jaw right to the body robinson comes
back to the right on the nose come on
drives him across the ring a left and a
right to the head let's get to the body
and robinson is driven out of the ring
for the first knockdown of his career
i have a gun
at my head
if a man who identifies himself as
the king
card's upside down
is not allowed to be the first guest on
you got a blank card funny how i mean
what's funny about it
tommy you know you got it all wrong oh
anthony he's a big boy he knows what he
said what'd you say
funny how dude
what just you know you're you're funny
you mean so man let me understand this
because you know maybe it's me a little
[ __ ] up maybe
but i'm funny how i mean funny like i'm
a clown i amuse you i make you laugh
i'm here to amuse you what do you mean
funny funny how how am i funny
i'm not just you know how you tell a
story what
no no i don't know you said it how do i
know you said i'm funny
how the [ __ ] am i funny what the [ __ ] is
so funny about me
tell me tell me what's funny
get up
what do you mean what's the matter man a
lot of money for you i want my cut
what money i've seen you spending from
me what money look at the stack of chips
don't give me that [ __ ]
i want to
yes
[Music]
food
baby oh
baby
my sweet baby
oh
sad something just came off the building
what do you mean something came off the
building go again with that
we can't get a visual do you want us to
get out of the car we got to get on foot
if you want me to get up on this thing
where the [ __ ] were you what the [ __ ]
happened wait get in the vine what do
you mean something came off the roof
what's going on
get in the burn i don't know if sarge
but i got four round men right out front
you want us to pursue no do not pursue
stay in the car some information what
came off the roof
not gonna leave i love you
so much
i'm just bombs in a box teddy oh
i um
you have to wake up
you're here
i'm not you have to face that
but she is
so is he
i have to go
you have to let me go
i can't
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i hope you know that what is in the
[Applause]
house
[Music]
all right
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
and break your face
[Music]
you